San Diego 36 hours that's all the time
teacher there tell me what it was like
picking up the unknown number phone call
yes
it's Tuesday night yeah all right it's
two days after I screen tested in New
York so typically like when you're an
actor and you know you any audition that
you go to like the whole like be a Dodge
is like sure leave it at the door
do your best job and then just forget
about it and if they call they call
right this was not one of those times
this was like every single second was
excruciating and every time my phone
buzz my heart skipped a beat like it was
a very it was a very unhealthy
equilibrium state let's just say so
I waited I waited two days and and I
thought like you know I'd been like
going online and and and watching like
all these YouTube videos of other Marvel
stars and how they got cast or how they
found out and and I got into my mind
that like I think Kevin likes to call
them personally mm-hmm so I was like you
know if my manager calls I might be bad
news but if I get a call from an unknown
number might be good news right so it's
about 619 p.m. on Tuesday and lo and
behold I'm in my underwear eating shrimp
crackers and lo and behold I'm no number
from Burbank California now I know that
Disney headquarters at Disney studio is
in Burbank and so my heart's thumping
out of my chest I jump up and I'm like
hello and and the divine voice of Kevin
Feige I'll never forget it so calm so
booming is like steam ooh hi we'd like
you to play shang-chi also you need to
go to comic-con in four days I was like
what what yeah I I don't know I can't I
can't describe how I felt I think that
cried hysterically I can't remember if
it was on the phone or after but
probably a bit of both so where does
your mind go because knowing that you
have been obsessed with this idea mm-hmm
for years I mean that we have the
receipts you've been bringing them back
up on Twitter talking about it right
basically almost manifesting this whole
thing so immediately where does your
mind go when when you know it's Kevin
on the line I don't think it goes
anywhere yeah I think goes I think it
goes in circles I think it goes like
that no I honestly like I couldn't
process it and and you know just having
to go to San Diego so quickly but then
also not being with to tell anybody
yeah was was really hard I mean I told
my parents but yeah but it was just like
it was just like holding it in holding
it in for this for this announcement
that was gonna happen right and when it
finally when I finally showed up in San
Diego and I remember very clearly we
were loading up in the de town cars and
I just saw like just all of the
characters that I had watched on screen
over the last like 11 years just passing
by it was like there's Black Widow
there's Hawkeye there's Loki there's
Thor and I was and I was one of them it
was like it it that was kind of when it
hit for me there's a great picture with
everybody up on holiday and it's like
you next to Benedict Cumberbatch yes and
like you know he's like clinging on to
you like you guys are pals because he's
going yeah yeah right um we've all been
saying that when you got up there and
you spoke to the crowd you were so
composed it seemed like you were so
prepared like you're like all these
beautiful people like you know the
audience is that something that you had
been going over and over in your head or
like when you walked up there was a
chest I just got it I'm here with them
yeah and I gotta be got to be one of
them I think yeah I think you hit the
nail on the head I mean I don't think
there was any way to prepare for 8,000
people who have some of which have been
camping out in order to see you yeah and
so I just felt like I owed it I owed it
to them I owed it to the world just to
like be present in that moment and what
I felt in that moment was just this year
like gratitude of everything and so I
tried to let that show yeah the thing
that I was running through in my mind
actually I don't know if you remember
but I spoke Mandarin off the top mhm
that was a Kevin Feige idea that came
about way too late on in the process and
so I was like struggling I was like
going to house I gotta say
because my manner is good but it's not
written so I had to I definitely had to
rehearse with myself a little bit so I'm
glad I think that part went really
beautifully I thought you know it's a
great way to make an introduction for a
character that is culturally Chinese and
you know I can't wait you know not only
for Asian audiences here in Canada and
America to watch it but also you know
Asian audiences in Asia mm-hmm I think
that'll be such an amazing experience
just to witness well I mean growing up
being a like a fan of Marvel or a fan of
comic books myself - mm-hmm
there's not an Avenger that you get to
be right not really I mean if you know
Shashank - you really know comic books
but if you don't there's really not
someone for you necessarily so you know
I'm sure one of the big things on your
mind is like the impact that this is
going to have yeah I think about when I
was a kid and deciding who to dress up
as for Halloween yeah I didn't really
have necessarily an option that directly
spoke to me so I mean I was Green
Lantern I was Captain America I ran the
gamut because I loved superheroes I
think that there are our modern-day like
you know Greek gods you know you have
like the Damocles and like Achilles well
today we have Thor and we have Captain
America these like larger-than-life
legendary people and and it's it feels
crazy to me now hopefully that in a
couple of years people will be able to
dress up as shang-chi and and you know
my hope is that it doesn't stop there
because it can't stop there yeah shanky
is only one and there are many that have
to come after him and you mentioned
telling your parents earlier on number
one what was their reaction right
because like obviously they've been
following your career and I don't know
if your parents are like my parents but
every now and again they might go okay I
see that this thing is going is going
well you know are you sure you don't
want to go to law school I've gotten
that I get that all the time right right
and so when you told them you know it
was a really emotional moment for me
because my mom said I mean I mean my
parents are very muted
in the reaction so there's no screaming
but there was just the sense of like a
pressure had been lifted and my mom said
she actually said you know next time I
get the chance to retire I'm gonna do it
hey and that just meant the absolute
world to me because my parents have been
working so hard ever since they you know
they came into this country and you know
they they sacrificed everything to be
able to raise me here so that I could
have the opportunity to do this and and
so it just it just meant the world that
you know I was able to even in a small
way give back to that yeah you know back
in your accounting days mm-hmm you know
when you're working there and you were
maybe dreaming of doing something
different doing this could you ever
imagine it and if you could go back and
and say to that guy you know yeah it'll
be all right like what would you what
would you tell them I would tell them
absolutely nothing because because as we
know an end game time travel is a very
tricky thing you can't just you can't
just you know go back in time and tell
yourself you know this is if you tell
yourself that something's gonna happen
it might not happen
yeah I'm just throwing endgame
references that you left right and
center but I believe that everything you
know if I can maybe just slip one bit of
wisdom is that everything will happen
exactly the way that it's meant to and
and just not to worry so much I'm sure
that's you know the same thing with you
like you know we're all just so anxious
when we're younger so we don't know we
don't know how things are gonna pan out
and you know there's something really
beautiful about that and we should not
always know we can't just we should just
allow yeah yeah now you like to stay in
good shape obviously you play ball you
work out a lot right you've been shot
good but yeah you've been showing people
that you do you know you have to figure
shape but are you ready for being like
Marvel shaped like what is ahead of you
in terms of how you what kind of
physical work you've got to deal with
the kind of training that you've got to
do for martial arts everything you know
I I'm reporting for duty in a couple
weeks so I think I'll find out man but I
know we
we have an amazing creative team
assembled we have an awesome stunt team
that has already you know reached out
and and we're talking it's gonna be a
lot of fun crafting the movements of
this character crafting how he fights
and how that form evolves over the
course of the movie as well I mean I
don't know what it is even if I did I
probably couldn't tell you yeah but I
know it's gonna be amazing when one fans
see it yeah in 2021 you know as an actor
when you're doing your like
visualization exercises right and you
look forward to this moment
mm-hmm is this panning out the way you
saw it pan out because we've been you
know and it's beyond anything yeah I
ever could have imagined it kind of I
mean I know I tweeted about it I know
that you know that I tweeted about it
but you know just sometimes we just
retweet things yeah it's crazy to me
that it came true it's it's not because
I tweeted it by the way I mean I think I
think you're right I think that was part
of my visualization exercise all those
years ago but yeah this is this is we've
officially reached a level of atmosphere
beyond anything that I've ever imagined
yeah I'm right now struggling with just
trying to figure out how to set new
goals because it was like my one my one
goal in life had just been had just been
reached well that's it there's like
Oscar mm-hm and I think that might be
the next one but that's those are the
things right yeah yeah so you got one
like you're here now it's it's crazy
it's like not not in the sense that you
wouldn't have gotten here but in the
sense that here you are experiencing
this now and that it all came together
in the span of like in the span of like
a week yeah is I think the craziest part
is you spend your it's the you know you
spend your whole life reading about
superheroes and dreaming about one day
being one and then in like in like a day
they're just like okay it really felt
like Cinderella it felt like a fairy
godmother like waved a magic wand and
then all of a sudden tada
and I'm like at the ball did you
spend a moment in the mirror by yourself
just like yes like how did you celebrate
on your own
I cried hysterically yeah as one might
I'm told that they were gonna be the
next title hero in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah no it was it was a really
great moment so is this kind of a lesson
in the idea of manifesting things
putting in the universe sometimes people
want a thing but they're afraid to say
hmm what they want absolutely I think
when I was when I was an accountant I
think the one thing that I was was I was
scared I was scared of of admitting that
I wasn't passionate about what I was
doing and I was scared of admitting that
I had always been interested in in
performance and in acting and I think
that when you start to give yourself
permission to feel these things and when
you start to be unapologetic about the
goals that you said your life is just
gonna become more focused as you move to
achieve that goal hmm it's it happens on
a subconscious level I mean of course
there's there's active things that you
can do as well but I just felt like I
just feel like the more focus that
vision is the more focused your life
will be now marveled is notoriously
secretive about things like we know that
and that's for our benefit I think I
think so yeah but it must be hard to
keep this in must have been a bit
difficult to keep this to yourself did
your cast at Kim's kind of know this
before they were supposed to know this
in a way you know what now that now that
I know that nolleke had actually sprung
yes I mean I mean there were a couple of
leakages along the way especially as it
got closer to the date I really hope
Kevin's not watching by the way but no I
think everybody everybody that I told
understood and and by the way everybody
on Kim's from the cast to like our
producers were so amazingly supportive
and I really I mean this show has meant
everything to me and there is no
opportunity today for me without Kim's
comedians on so so many levels I mean I
learned comic timing through this show
and through the four seasons four
amazing seasons that I've been working
on and hopefully we'll be coming back
for for the fifth yeah
I've just had the best time with the
best parents when I talked to Kevin you
mentioned that you'd come in for a bunch
of auditions that you were phenomenal on
and all of them
you were stand out and all of them what
were the auditions like what did you do
were you acting with somebody were you
reading on your own so there was there
was kind of like a videotape component
in the very beginning yeah I was still
shooting Kim's at the time yeah and and
kind of make it over but then there was
a there was a callback when I met the
director and then finally and really I'm
trying to do the math I think it was ten
days ago was the it honestly feels like
an eternity yet ten days ago was my
screen test in New York yeah yeah it's
crazy man it's like the trip life's a
trip man well listen we're super excited
I'm excited I again having been a comic
fan and knowing who Shane she is the
moment they announced that it was gonna
happen and it was gonna be you it was
like a double hit it was insane oh right
and I'm excited I said you know well
truly J and so you know I hope you take
us on this adventure with you too man
cuz we're so excited for you thank you
so much yeah I can't wait I can't wait
to get to work in to show the world
right nothing
you